[Music]
so one thing that I noticed about
behavior modification and the cigarettes
example comes to mind is there's the
laws right and taxes that got passed but
there was also a change in social norms
it used to be that cigarette smoking was
like really cool and now it's really not
cool and perhaps we can be doing that
for making the behaviors that we noticed
to be incredibly unhealthy just super
not cool right somehow you gain a lot of
Instagram followers by posting your cool
outfit every single day and like getting
the hashtags right and instead maybe we
just make it not cool to care so much
about what internet strangers think
about your outfit or just not cool to be
checking Twitter when you're in a place
where you can instead be making eye
contact and talking to strangers and I
want some suggestions from you guys
about how we can make those social norms
in alignment with healthy uses of some
of these technologies I'll start in the
last 30 years there have been four count
them for cultural tectonic shifts in
this country bicycle helmets and seat
belts smoking in public places
drunk driving condoms and bathrooms damn
30 years ago both were that's a good
list condoms and bathrooms
you know HIV you know anti-hiv hundin's
and yeah yeah yeah yeah and public
bathrooms for sanitary purposes right
thirty years ago if a legislator in a
State House or Congress suggested any
one of those they'd have been laughed
out of town never would have gotten
reelected today they're all facts of
life hmm okay you see a guy on the
street today smoking you feel sorry for
him right okay
my goal is shortly maybe within the next
five to ten years you see a guy drinking
a coke on the street you're gonna feel
sorry for him well good so the question
is how do you do that and why does it
take 25 years answer you teach the
children you teach the children it
becomes inculcated in their ethos as to
what is right and what is wrong and then
guess what they grow up in they vote and
all the people who are yelling nanny
state and you know forget it you know
forget about it okay they're all dead
that's what it takes and it takes a
generation so we but we have to but you
have to start this at some time well
this technology thing we're just like
we're not even we're in the pre
contemplative stage we're not even there
yet the the weird thing though that's
different is with all those other
changes the old people like didn't get
the condoms or the seatbelts or the
cigarettes or right and the young people
saw the benefits of not getting HIV and
not getting your brain splattered on the
concrete but now it's all the old people
who see the problems with the technology
that all was young people are using
right and so there's that switch I
wonder if that means that we need some
different approach for creating social
norms hey also we don't have 20 years to
get people uh Nick today's book one last
thing I'll say about that is I
personally agree with you in the sense
that I don't think the current or the
old systems of educating people will be
a fully selective effective
solution because these technologies that
we use actually are useful whereas drunk
driving and not wearing your seatbelt
and smoking none of those things are
actually useful to your life you can you
they're all expendable you can get rid
of them or change your behavior and make
your life better whereas with technology
we're forced to use technology so I
personally abstain from all substances I
don't drink I don't use any drugs I
don't even really take medication that
much however I'm not able to avoid
technology it's just impossible you know
so you can't educate people and tell
them oh you know you should know all the
the risks and benefits of using the
Internet to do your homework research
particular their willpower to overcome
the addictive things have been built
into those search engines that they use
to find stuff and you know how
effectives is that really gonna be it's
kind of like if you tell everyone to
wear seatbelts and cars and like no cars
have seatbelts it's like well great you
know thanks for letting me know but you
know it's not available yeah but they
don't have to use social media I mean
technology is one thing and I understand
the importance and the amazing phenomena
that can come from you know use use of
technology in the right way
like for instance those one-way apps
yeah I'm talking about the two-way apps
yeah you don't have to use face nobody
has to use Facebook
Facebook's a choice the question is
why'd you make that choice and what's in
it for you and ultimately is it
short-term gain for long-term pain and
ultimately that's a question that every
addict has to address that for
themselves mm-hmm hi I've enjoyed this
so much it's not normal and so I have to
give out some awards best socks that's
asked you most patient you're coming at
the end most like mr. Rogers of
neuroscience most like who I want my son
to be and most like Internet dad okay I
don't know why those are the case that's
just the thing need to have some kids
for
you want mine I've never had any anyone
at any event do give awards I know like
nobody cares what I think in this no
Robert Robert right do you have any idea
what the optics were like when first of
all I claimed no expertise I have not at
UCSF I have not I'm a parent
I've been marinating neuroscience
screens and many other issues that orbit
around the ecosystem productivity
Charles Duhigg love that's why it's
weird that how interested I am in all of
this yet the optics of how important it
was for you to get that data that if you
think about the value of the overall
discussion and whether that was a net
negative or net positive I swear to God
I have no judgment but do you have any
idea about what that looked like up on
the panel while you were sitting with
your esteemed colleagues and I don't
blame you but it's consciousness it was
a long time you were surfing the
internet no I wasn't I was going through
my PowerPoint trying to find the slide
wait no again it whatever you were doing
the Internet I was using my powerpoint
that's on my iPad okay but the point is
is you were to head down a device
searching for a data point and I only
asked if that's a net positive to the
overall evening or a net negative and I
asked that with a parent mind we do it I
do it
okay I don't I'm not I'm not I'm not
literally its consciousness my point is
consciousness here simply that I come
from the parent standpoint of a parent
I'm teaching parents how to teach their
children how to get their kids off
screens to have tech life balance and
then to teach them about focus time
management and goal-setting okay who the
hell wants to do that but I noticed it
the question the question is is the role
that consciousness plays in addressing
the overall problem
I I'm going to coop to the question and
say that it was a net negative in my
opinion because humans mimic other
humans and when people start looking at
their screens in a context like this
then other people also start looking at
their screens and they inherently become
disconnected because as you said you're
no longer looking eye to eye with the
people on stage or the people around you
you're now in your own world where
you're trying to find that thing and
finally I've actually also seen that
study so I know exactly what all the
data is I definitely remembered the
grinder was the number one app on that
for what it's worth I found it to be
extremely positive and a really
important point but I would have said
one mentation would have been to just be
like I have to I want to show you guys
this really cool point and I'm just
gonna quickly find it in my powerpoint
and that and that's it but I think it
was really important to show us that
going inward with those apps rather than
going outward that was a really good
point I I knew and I apologized in their
rate usage is a big thing that we teach
kid I really truly in all honesty claim
no moral superiority here I do it all
the time I'm a parent and my wife and
kid yeah hate when I do it too I mean
and I got it I'm I'm with you and I knew
I was doing it and iced and it still
sucked have you been doing under
computer at the whole time taking notes
thank you thank you
actually I would say so do we know that
you know now we know that you're taking
notes but actually to look at you would
we would we know right so I I in in my
lab right we're you know weird
neurosciences we work on laptops all the
day all day long right I we have a lot
of meetings where there's an OLAP
topical not even because people aren't
working but because you don't know you
can't tell right away by looking and so
it's about creating the norm and the
expectation and the feeling of respect
for other people and you know what I've
learned to do I take paper notes and
then I scan them into Evernote which I
love you can you can do that you can do
that that's a that's a good thing
there's a really good one
I just want I'm an obsessive compulsive
note-taker and so for me I enter into
the meeting saying is it okay if I take
notes
on my digital device and so yeah so
anyway there's all these different ways
modalities of for approaching this point
yet yes new question there's a there's a
lot of talk of regulations around the
social media space sorry what was that
word sorry Oh regulations okay yeah
there's there's talk of regulations in
the social media space and it's a few
panelist panelists actually mentioned a
little bit on it today I was wondering
if anyone knew of any promising
regulations that are worth like
discussing that are you know there
there's some people to say no
regulations at all some people say we
need to you know people you don't want
to over regulate but what are some
actual practical regulations that are
worth discussing
damn imagine if you could only use the
Facebook for like an hour a day period
like it's just mandated you had no other
choice like would you be more effective
when you use the platform like would you
only go and post what you need and
message who you need and be done with it
it's just interesting thoughts around
regulation you know what so many other
things to regulate what do you guys have
you guys heard of any regulations do you
guys can you creatively envision any
interesting regulations can i yeah so I
just want to put out one idea I think
would you know be important to this
unhealthy attention economy which is
data ownership so one of the reasons why
these companies are you know trying to
capture your attention is so they can
learn about you and build these
unbelievably sophisticated profiles of
you which then are they sell to
advertisers right so that's kind of a
linchpin of this whole economy and right
now we have no rights to that data we
have no rights to even know what data
there is so gdpr is I don't know all the
ins and outs of it it's a step towards
that but I don't
my understand it's not it doesn't go the
whole way yeah I certainly under gdpr
can't ask to see all my data and have it
and then you know reclaim it or you know
have the rights to it it doesn't count
as my property I think that's a really
interesting idea that we could explore
regulatory your your data I mean the
fact that you've already went and built
this amazing social network through the
through the
actions you've made throughout your life
and you want to you want to get this
data in a way that's beautiful way and
parse it and make it relatable to you
and make it easy for you to do what you
want with it in the future and you can't
you can't do that it's it's a joke it's
the most valuable asset one of the most
valuable assets you have and I actually
am skeptical personally of how much
knowing the data about you would really
change your behavior and change your
life for example recently iOS 12 Apple
rolled out a feature called screen time
that lets you see how much you're using
certain types of apps on your phones and
actually before that I've been tracking
my own internet usage extremely
carefully in very minor detail for the
last nine months and I must say that for
me personally it's really had no impact
whatsoever on my own behavior because
these paths of dopamine have already
been created and it's not like knowing
that it's happening is really gonna help
you overcome that what you really
actually need is a way to substitute
that wiring in your brain that
expectation of dopamine with something
else that is hopefully healthier or
something in there there's nothing
that's gonna substitute in your brain
for dopamine yeah it's it's a core part
of how your neural wiring works every
action you take is motivated by dopamine
every everything in life you find
rewarding is motivated some level about
dopamine
oh I know but I'm just saying but will
here here might be an interesting way
for you to potentially explore a process
like this it would be doing something I
came back from my fourth 10-day
meditation retreat there's no technology
there's no eye contact there's no
talking and when you're there all you're
doing is you're going inward and you're
meditating and you're reclaiming your
mind from the obsessive monkey mind
thought patterns that it has hold on
hold on hold on hold on and so and so
now think think about this is that
potentially a way to change the neural
architecture of your mind for the better
to go ten days without using the
technology because the creative thoughts
that I had in this last 10-day
experience were some of the
best creative thoughts I've ever had in
my life and I was able to redirect
myself with my attention in a in a
really positive way moving forward and I
figured out who I should be talking to
and who I should stop talking to so I
think about it like genetic expressions
of connections that I don't I want to
open up expressions and turn off certain
expressions I did that too wasn't
effective because I've grown up with
this and it's wired my brain from an
extremely early age in a way that would
take a lot longer than 10 days to
overcome you've been to attend a
meditation retreat but do you have a how
many days at it have you went at a time
with okay this this is not about
regulation this is about what
individuals can do in my book I
basically say there are three things
that ultimately have to come of this you
have to up your serotonin you have to
tamp down your dopamine you have to
reduce your cortisol which is a stress
hormone that actually makes your
prefrontal cortex fry now there are four
things that I know of they're all
evidence-based they're all clinically
proven to be effective or your money
back but none of them cost anything so
don't expect a refund I call them the
four C's and I'll do a real fast connect
and that does not mean Facebook
contribute and that does not mean to
your IR a cope and that's sleep
mindfulness and exercise okay sleep
because sleep Frye's your pre from lack
of sleep fries your prefrontal cortex
mindfulness is exercising your
prefrontal cortex and it turns out
exercise alleviates depression all by
itself and if you do mindfulness plus
exercise you reverse depression with no
meds huh inside yeah yeah oh yeah inside
exercise right sure with a HEPA filter
and number four cook because there are
three items in food that matter
tryptophane precursor to serotonin found
in eggs poultry fish not exactly
processed food
omega-3 fatty acids which are
anti-inflammatory and cause in when you
have them in enough enough of them you
get improved neurotransmission
especially in serotonin and finally
sugar which that ups dopamine tamps down
serotonin so a high sugar high a low
omega-3 low tryptophane diet that's
called processed food a low sugar high
omega-3 high tryptophane diet that's
called real food so cook is number four
and self regulating yourself for these
four C's yeah now those are things you
can do right now to improve your life
the question is it what if you can't
that's where society has to help you
that's what society is about that's why
we have society is to help you do the
things you can't do yourself just one
fun regulation idea yeah I haven't seen
anywhere but I don't think that
smartphone interfaces should by defaults
present a vending machine of corporate
logos I I think Twitter and some other
apps come install default on the iPhone
and Android handsets have various
partnerships but yeah that's why I was
like have you seen see if you haven't
yet if you have an Android phone
download cm Poe and give it a go because
the home screen for CFO is no there's no
vending machine corporate logos it is
just a bar that you get to write an
intention into what you want out of the
day and so I write hope or love or
consciousness or coherence or whatever
there and it changes everything cuz when
you unlock your phone there's no apps so
you're like oh what am i on my never
mind and that happens to me a lot yeah
yeah that is the thing you see a hundred
two hundred times a day yeah that's the
most valuable real estate is your home
screen on your cell phone right and what
if it were designed to promote corporate
logos Kristin Harris taught me this
trick so
what is that three clicks and you get
black-and-white three clicks and you get
black my tool now it's an entertainment
interesting that that's that that's a
pretty good uh it's interesting I bet
that entertainment versus tool by going
to black and white so yeah I mean I
focus on individual interventions in
most of my work but I think it's really
important that we be thinking that both
of the you know things on both sides are
necessary right so with tobacco
we need tobacco treatment about smoking
cessation programs right but we really
really did need the tobacco industry to
be regulated and they were new for many
many years they were producing a product
that was unhealthy and I think that and
we could potentially take the same
public health approach to technology
companies especially social media
companies gaming companies that if they
know they're producing a product that is
detrimental to mental health it's
harmful to mental health that the that
we we actually obligate those companies
to act on that information and to change
their products so that's no longer the
case and maybe require them to do that
research the same way we require the
products that are brought in the market
for physical consumption be considered
safe Joe had this really interesting
point on the phone the phone call we had
just yesterday where you said that so
many people can enjoy a single glass of
wine and there's so many alcoholics and
then there are so many people that are
social media addicts but how what do we
classify as the person I can just go in
tap in get what they need just the glass
of wine for social media right how do we
set up our society so our systems our
institutions and our social norms and
our individual habits and behaviors
together so that we can kind of enjoy a
good glass of Chianti with dinner and
not be you know going on a bender like
as he put it
one interesting distinction actually I
interviewed a psychologist recently and
in her opinion she believes that a
larger percentage of the population is
liable to become addicted to variable
reward behaviors versus chemical
dependency because chemical dependency
has a stronger genetic component than
variable rewards variable rewards are
just rewiring the brain connections that
you already have and basically everyone
has so a larger percentage of the
population can kind of fall victim to
that given the right circumstances
versus enjoying a glass of wine versus
becoming alcoholic thank you so much
this has been really fascinating um
I want to go back to that question of
consciousness and direction of attention
there's been this is like a circularity
that I've been struggling with I guess
it's a little philosophical but I'm
interested in hearing you all ruminate
on it a little bit
I guess the argument is that technology
is distracting us from our goals it's
we're I think the phrase was
surrendering or surrendering our senses
to this external force and that this is
dangerous this is harmful but if you
think about you know how do we set goals
originally are we born with genetic the
goals built-in I don't think so I think
we set goals by opening up our senses by
playing and by deciding these are things
I want more of these are things I want
less of so in some ways starting our
senses is necessary to the generational
goals in the first place so how do we
deal with this circularity and what's
what's wrong in certain types of
surrender but what's right in others
pointing to me so I would say so firstly
I mean we do have certain we are born
with certain goals we are genetically
you know through evolution right our
survival depended on us being really
interested in you know feeding fighting
other things you know the start of death
and we so we you know that's that's part
of what we start out with and we also as
you say right as we learn we learn from
each other we kind of we're socialized
and then we do our own reflection
so I mean the thing that I really think
about in terms of attention is that in a
certain way just like previously we
didn't have refined sugar so we didn't
really have to in in previous
generations obesity wasn't a problem it
was desirable it was attractive it was a
sign of wealth right it's only in the
20th century when we had this abundance
of food and we have all every kind of
food Under the Sun that we have to think
the opposite way working out we didn't
used to work out that was used to be a
ridiculous idea the idea that you'd
voluntarily exhaust yourself physically
when life was already hard enough right
but now that we have so much convenience
we have sedentary lives so the same
thing is happening with the tension so
we used to be able we didn't used to
have these demands on our attention
scattering it right so and we're there's
we're not going back so we're gonna live
in a world where we can't take attention
for granted we can't take our own
attention for granted and so we need to
be thinking consciously how do we learn
to be conscious about where we put our
attention and what we bring in and I
think you know my in my experience like
my own meditation practice and the
teachings you know teachings in
meditation traditions I've been
extraordinarily helpful for me and think
about that I just got back from a
contemplative science research
conference this weekend and a lot of our
conversation is about how do we bring
these teachings into secular settings
where they're really accessible and
translate them and disseminate them
widely so that would be that we might
thought we can't take our attention for
granted anymore one thing okay go ahead
and add one thing yeah yeah so thank you
for your response
I'm also thinking in particular in in
childhood where
you know play is in and there's you know
the the development of the childhood in
the 50s and sort of onward there's been
so much thought about what is good play
and what is bad play so I think for a
long time our attention has been certain
controlled or guided by external forces
so I guess in particular I'm interested
in what qualities of those forces are
are good in bed maybe the pediatrician
I'm not going to be able to tell you
what's good play or bad play other than
play is good that's what I can say and
there and and there and the reason is
because number one it's imagination
number two it's determining consequences
of actions and that is what your
prefrontal cortex does this part of your
brain right behind your forehead okay
the Jiminy Cricket part of your brain
the part of your brain that keeps you
from doing stupid things okay
that requires exercise and that's what
mindfulness is we were talking about it
before is exercising your prefrontal
cortex ultimately sometimes you need to
exercise it so much that you're actively
doing nothing you know how hard it is to
actively do nothing it's amazing
squelch all of the running thoughts
across your brain the better you can do
that
the more Intune you are and the more
thoughtful you are the more
intellectually curious you are and the
less susceptible to fake news you are by
the way that's and there's real
honest-to-goodness
hard-wired fMRI data on that so where do
you teach that where do you learn that
well used to parents you know can
certainly start it okay it's also
something you learn in class you learn
in school you learn it in science you
learn how to critically think because
that is your prefrontal cortex is how to
critically think and right now we're not
critically thing
we are distracted when you're distracted
you can't think and just to take this in
a somewhat philosophical direction as
you drop the put the space there for
that show I just finished reading a book
recently called gulag by Anne Applebaum
on you know the concentration camps and
Stalin's and priests all in USSR when I
can see Alan's wondering how in the
world am I going to relate this back
here right but I think I think the big
answer to this question about how to how
to set goals and what goals we have as
humans is freedom and a lot of what
technology enables us to do it the
technology gives us is the more degrees
of that freedom and as innovators as
people who think deeply on this subject
it's our role and to some sense are our
duty and our responsibility to help
create even more degrees of freedom for
those people who are looking for
passionate and wonderful and fulfilling
ways to live fuller and more meaningful
lives before we move on to the next
question I'm actually you asked about
how children set their goals to and how
they want they formulate what they want
to do when they grow up I think when you
know historically for basically all of
human history children did that by
watching the people around them and
emulating the goals that the social
group that they were part of also had
and that's why you had kids fifty years
ago saying that they want to be a police
officer or a fireman or a lawyer or a
congress person because that was what
the people around them I've heard kids
say that before anyway so you know it's
what the goal is what the objectives of
they're their parents and their peers
and their teachers and and other little
children around them had nowadays people
are no longer focusing on the people
around them they're focusing on this
really abstract concept of the Internet
where they're seeing all these different
images of people and images of things
that aren't people and and it's kind of
all over the map and I can see why
children have a much harder time
answering the question what do you want
to be when you grow up because they
don't really have any metric to kind of
like figure out what they actually want
to do
they're just getting directed in ten
different directions all the time by the
media they consume through technology
maybe that's a good thing right maybe
there's so many more ways that they can
go in life
that they're not they're not just seeing
you know the firemen and that's all they
think about or you know the the
astronaut and that's all they think
about but they're seeing so many other
possibilities because of the amount of
signal and noise that they're exposed to
that that maybe it's a good thing that
they say well what do you want to be
well I don't know because in all honesty
that is the much more honest answer you
know how many kids do they you know go
up and say oh I want to be a tax
accountant you know not too many right
butts how many of them are actually
gonna grow up to be tax accountants
versus astronauts right so maybe it's
it's it's so it's a wonderful and honest
moment that we're now seeing from our
children that they're willing to do this
by the way I know I feel defeated next
question at a conference at a conference
last week they're from the same company
know this technology conference someone
said that the answer to that question we
want to be when you're up most popular
answer is an Instagram influencer and
then a year ago I was just about to say
that when he was giving his name when he
was giving his list I thought that was
gonna be the answer famous was I thought
it was good yeah another source I think
you may have been the screen Agers
documentary which is fantastic
especially if you're interested in the
children screen Agers screen Agers yeah
yeah really good there lots of showings
around the Bay Area I think the answer
in Silicon Valley was to be a venture
capitalist Wow you know watching two
years I bet the kids are gonna say they
want to be a tick tock influencer so
just one more question and just to say
on the on the the skill I think of the
next decade to develop is that silence
is that ability to come completely take
the thoughts that are going business
businesses and just think I'm in control
I'm focusing on my breath and what that
does for you over time is you'll you'll
see in your relationships and in your
work and then everything else you do
last question one more question I have
something like a game
that I'd like the panelist to play if
they want oh my gosh Ward's the game
it's also question it is there an app on
your phone that you can chose right now
that would be extremely painful for you
to delete right now what you can just do
right now and make your life better and
you can make me start if you like
interesting an app on the phone that the
weeds yeah delete like right now yeah
interesting I have an answer to this
question that actually change its
recently because I did that multi-day
kind of like meditation retreat and one
thing that I was super nervous about was
driving into the wilderness without
Google Maps it turns out if you don't
have Google Maps on your phone there's
all these things called street signs
that like tell you exactly where you are
whenever I'm driving and you don't
realize them when you use Google Maps
because you're just looking at your
phone all the time and listening for the
phone within not actually scanning your
surroundings to see like where you are
so it turns out that navigating without
Google Maps was extremely easy and yet
if you ask me that two months ago I
would have probably thought it was
impossible god forbid you stopped at a
local gas station asked for directions
yeah that's a good question do you guys
have answers to that yeah notes cloud
sync notes I think it's the most utility
I get from a smart phone which is that I
can jot down any nuggets of wisdom
recommendations thoughts and they're
synced across my devices and it's like a
backup brain the question was about
deletion so like would you be like
what's an app on your phone that you
would delete like that you would want to
delete right now I thought that's what
we wouldn't want to delete it it's wood
it's wood if you don't want to delete it
that might be the one that you want to
delete right that's something I do not
want to delete yeah okay with Google
Maps interesting because you brought up
suppose do the right and I'll see where
my life is this is a good point it's a
quantified self experience in general
just at least go for a day without
talking go for a day without touching
your phone go for a day and set yourself
up to that you know your loved ones know
that even they can't
own free day yeah just and experience
these things for yourself and see what
it feels like just yeah it Judaism it's
called Shabbat and that's what it was
for is for resetting mm-hmm the app I
would lose text messaging I'd be
delighted to lose text messaging also
I'm actually not sure iOS lets you
delete it to be completely honest all
right last last last just just just to
take the question and and actually send
it in a direction that you all might be
interested in there is an app called Wii
croak it's now the first app on my phone
it's it sends you five times a day it
sends you a quote about death and you
you read you read the quote and this is
a practice I believe of the Taoist
practice which is that the more times
that you contemplate death every single
day the more happy and present you are
in the moment so I highly recommend we
croak it's so 99 cents on Android and
iOS and it's it's I get no cut then okay
and that's that's the beauty of things
right yeah yeah it's that's that's the
beauty things Wow this has been really
helpful and really enlightening there's
there's there's this very fascinating
thing that happened when we said that we
were putting together a social media and
attention economy event which was that
all these like professors and
researchers and entrepreneurs that are
focused in the space replied to saying
that oh whoa they were like shocked that
we could do events around this theme and
it just it requires people to practice
making events around pressing themes
like this and if you're in a field that
has pressing themes ethical or moral
themes go and make events reach out to
people that are of clout in those fields
that have good things to ship and host
events about them because we're going to
be doing this more often because this is
a very pressing and nuanced
discussion and I want to thank everyone
for coming out thank you so much for
coming out everyone in the audience our
panel thank you so much I there's just a
couple things that we probably need to
say one of the things is that a good way
to when's the next civility and how can
people get involved we have we have
civility discussions all the time we
have a couple coming up this weekend
it's the the brilliance of it is that
whatever topic anybody's interested
including this topic you can sign up for
it and you can see what discussions are
coming up or start your own if you're
interested in this topic and we help
coordinate the people and promote the
discussion and everything and people can
come together to actually have always an
in-person face-to-face discussion in a
small group of six and always a
stimulating intellectually engaging
discussion so that's that to me was a
very important part of fulfilling that
that sense that one gets in college of
being able to have these these sorts of
things and what we're having up here on
this on this stage really bringing that
to to all of us in a very big in scale
of a way so that's that's that's it
that's my contribution our contribution
to yeah to changing this this situation
we're stuck in its civility dot social
and you can find all the information
there we're we're simulation series comm
our next upcoming event is with Adam
Gazelle II on on December 14th at work
wise as well we're look really looking
forward to that's on the cognition
crisis so we'll actually be touching a
lot of similar subjects that we talked
about today and besides that you know
how important it is to build the future
go and manifest your destiny into the
world go and execute go build go create
we love you so much thank you for coming
out
[Applause]
[Music]